[Music]
this award is so much larger than me
this moment is about visibility and
about representation singer Troye Sivan
was honored at the GLAAD Media Awards
with the Steven F Kohl's AK Award for
his work in promoting equality his
parents flew in from Melbourne Australia
for the occasion
the housing photos shared this moment
with them so so so awesome they came out
from Melbourne for this and yeah to be
with them tonight I wouldn't have it any
other way and I'm just so proud of them
and the journey that they've been on as
parents of a queer kid they they just
couldn't it under better at 21
Troy is the youngest recipient of the
award ET also caught up with him at the
first ever glad rising stars luncheon
honoring young LGBT activists for the
young people out there who throw a lien
a theatres are struggling because they
feel different would you say to them I
would say it sounds so cliche to say but
the things that made me weird at school
are the things that are now my job and
my life and the things that are like
most celebrated I guess about me and so
it often works out like that so what's
on the horizon for Troy well he's in the
studio working on his follow-up to his
debut album blue neighbourhood what kind
of stories are you telling this
go-around oh I don't know yeah I've
literally just thought of like two weeks
ago so it's all sort of coming together
but I'm really excited I'm so excited
for this album I think I have a real
clear vision in my head at this time
around how personal are you going on
this record
super super personal always I think that
yeah you know for me like honesty is the
best policy especially when it comes to
music
[Music]
you